foreign
[Music]
that Asia is the largest and most
populated continent in the world and
that within Asia was also the most
populous country on the planet China
however this is no longer the case India
overtakes China to become the most
populous country indeed what was long
predicted has finally happened India has
overtaken China in population according
to estimates in July 2023 India already
outnumbers China by a mere 3 million
people but this Gap will increase over
time to give you an idea experts
estimate that China's population will
fall steadily to 800 Million by the end
of the century meanwhile India will
reach 1.7 billion by 2060 and will end
the century with about 1.5 billion
inhabitants in other words by the end of
the 21st century India's population will
be practical double that of China so
what does this mean for China it's a
challenge for example by 2050 there will
be 700 million workers in China 200
million fewer than in 2011 and these 700
million will also have to face the costs
of having 500 million Chinese over the
age of 60. that's 300 million more than
there are today and not only that China
also risks losing one of its greatest
strengths cheap labor even so we are not
going to talk to you about China today
we're going to talk to you about the new
demographic Champion that India has
become
[Music]
a country that is still very poor and
still has a long way to go to match
China in terms of economic productivity
or standard of living and the question
is why is that well we could highlight
many factors excessive bureaucracy
aggressive protectionism the caste
system we recently told you about and
also its chronic inability to develop
one crucial factor for economic
development having robust infrastructure
which is precisely what we're going to
dedicate this video to but visualpolitik
viewers how did India get here how is
Narendra Modi dealing with the challenge
of a chronic lack of infrastructure
could India become the next Global
manufacturing epicenter which industry
could put XI jinping's geopolitical
plans in check we will answer all of
these questions but first let's look at
a bit of history and by the way if you
want to discover a unique kind of
content here on YouTube literally
changing the world for the better stay
watching until the end of this video
there we have a special recommendation
from our friends at Planet wild that you
shouldn't miss
[Music]
the Indian political Dynasty
let's start with a question that may
catch you off guard what do you know
about the history of India surely many
of you know some facts about Mahatma
Gandhi and his commitment to non-violent
protest and I'm sure most of you know
that the country was a former British
colony but anything else most probably
not much more typically India is only
highlighted for its huge population yet
this giant is much more than that and
its history is crucial for understanding
today's India
[Applause]
thank you well given that its
independence from the British Empire
happened in 1947 under the leadership of
Gandhi India is a relatively young
federal state from the very beginning it
had to face a very unproductive economic
scenario based on subsistence
agriculture up to 70 of the population
lived on subsistence farming however
after Gandhi's assassination in 1948 His
companion and leading Independence
figure jawaharlal nehru came to power
and India began its path to Economic
Development India's new prime minister
began to run the economy from within the
state and in 1951 created the country's
First Five-Year Plan this plan
nationalized mining the energy sector
and heavy industry all of these were
classified as strategic sectors a strict
licensing system was also implemented
which increased the bureaucracy to an
excessive degree all this meant that
during his term of office which lasted
until 1964 the economy barely managed to
grow by 2.5 percent this was
insufficient to put an end to Chronic
unemployment poverty and malnutrition
[Music]
Peter with the death of nehru in 1964
and that of his successor
shastri in 1966 came another of the most
important figures in the country's
history Indira Gandhi no she is not the
daughter of Mahatma but of nehru himself
[Music]
Indira Gandhi ruled from 1966 to 1984
almost uninterrupted except for the
three years between 1977 and 1980.
during the rest of the time she was Lady
and master of the country so what did
she do during her two terms in office
well basically she continued with her
father's economic plans she nationalized
the banking system the coal mines and
the oil companies among others even so
in spite of all this surely the main
Milestone of the Indian Prime Minister
was the eradication almost completely of
hunger through the well-known Green
Revolution and what did this revolution
consist of essentially the introduction
of crops with much higher yields such as
dwarf rice the widespread use of
fertilizers and pesticides and the
Improvement of irrigation systems
however in October 1984 four months
after a clash between the state and Sikh
separatists she was killed by some of
her bodyguards who professed the same
religion but visualpolitik viewers if
you thought that political dynasties
were only a Kennedy thing you're wrong
do you know who took the reins of the
country after Indira Gandhi's
assassination that's right her son Rajiv
Gandhi and what exactly did he do he
didn't really change too many things he
continued the legacy of his mother and
grandfather
it turned out however that India managed
to grow above 3 percent during the 1980s
and it even had some reasonably good
years the development given the
country's poverty level was nothing
special but apparently not a disaster
either nevertheless the problem was that
this growth had a catch to it for years
India grew thanks to debt and as
happened in Latin America in the early
1980s India suffered a financial crisis
in 1990. it was then that in 1991 under
the leadership of prime minister
narasimha Rao India began to open up to
the world bureaucracy was drastically
reduced by eliminating much of nehru's
Licensing system tariffs were lowered
and currency reserves eventually Grew
From 3 billion in 1991 to 25 billion
dollars in 1995. even so India still
lacked something that would consolidate
and expand its economic growth something
that neighboring China was already
developing infrastructure well thus
began the infrastructure drive in this
Asian subcontinent pay close attention
[Music]
make in India
foreign
needs infrastructure without roads power
plants or technology it is difficult for
a country to prosper in the 21st century
that's why countries in Africa are
working so hard with China because the
Asian giant is providing them with loans
and assistance for building all the
basic infrastructure that is essential
for development in India prime minister
atal bihari vajpayee became aware of all
this in 1998 and therefore launched the
famous golden quadrilateral project it's
a project that connects by Road four of
the country's main cities New Delhi in
the north Kolkata in the East Chennai in
the South and Bombay in the west or with
a view to improving economic exchanges
within the country but of course this
momentum did not stop there his
successor Manmohan Singh who came to
power in 2004 promoted the construction
of corridors dedicated to rail Freight
in fact it made these the main focus of
The
2007-2012 Five-Year Plan and today two
of these corridors are already in
operation the Western Corridor which is
1 500 kilometers long that's 932 miles
and the Eastern Corridor which is the
longest the 1900 kilometer or 1180 mile
long Corridor runs from Ludhiana the
most populous city in Punjab to Dan
Cooney which is part of the Kolkata
metropolitan area however in spite of
all this the truth is that progress was
still slow
and of course in such a densely
populated country with extraordinarily
large cities you can imagine what a huge
problem that is congested roads crowded
trains running at extremely slow speeds
power Cuts problems with delivery times
of goods and so on and so forth well it
was then suddenly in 2014 when one
particular figure who we have already
told you about on this channel burst
into Indian national politics Narendra
Modi in other videos we've already
talked about how Modi is managing the
Country complaints about the violation
of human rights are constant and many of
his economic promises came to
practically nothing yet he is still a
very popular politician in the country
and one of his great efforts in
particular has been and continues to be
to improve infrastructure and not like
his predecessors but on a massive scale
all under one initiative the make in
India initiative
thank you foreign
by Modi himself the make in India
initiative aims to make India the most
important manufacturing Hub in the world
even above China the aim is to increase
the presence of the manufacturing sector
from the current 17 to more than 25
along the way they hope to create 100
million jobs in this sector to this end
the Indian government has focused on
building better infrastructure that is
capable of attracting more investment
and encouraging innovation in 25
specific sectors including energy
chemicals electronics and the automotive
industry for the time being the
initiative seems to be paying off as
from FY 2012 to 13 to 2020-21 the main
year of the covid pandemic foreign
direct investment went from about 34
billion dollars to touch 82 billion
dollars
during this time Modi is pushed for the
construction of more than 10 000
kilometers or 6 200 miles of new
highways every year more than 45 new
civil airports have been built and
dozens more Under Construction New Ports
new Metro Transport Systems and also
thousands and thousands of kilometers of
new railroads have been developed across
the country the aim is to also achieve
one crucial objective to reduce the
country's Logistics costs which
currently stand at 14 of GDP to less
than eight percent of GDP by 2030.
efficient infrastructure is absolutely
key to the competitiveness of the
industrial sector you see visualpolitik
Community Modi has set the wheels in
motion for India to try to overtake
China not only in population but also in
manufacturing that is his big goal so
for the Indian Prime Minister the race
has only just begun
in fact the 2023 budget dedicated to
infrastructure construction has grown by
33 over the previous year to 3.3 percent
of GDP or 122 billion dollars in
addition they have also decided to
extend interest-free loans to 50 years
for all state governments that want to
invest in infrastructure and not only
that investment in artificial
intelligence especially for its
incorporation into education is also one
of its fundamental axes not surprisingly
they will continue to invest in the
freight corridors both in the two that
are almost finished and are now
operating at almost 100 as well as in
three other projects that have already
been approved yet despite all the
infrastructure construction there is one
problem that could drive investment away
from India analysis dark summer nights
India faces high risks of power Cuts
after years of coal Hydro power neglect
we are of course talking about
electricity Supply
India has been having power cuts for at
least three years now mostly at night
due to the shortage of coal and the
country's poor and outdated
infrastructure as you can imagine this
is a fundamental problem for the entire
industrial sector to solve this problem
India plans to build 26 coal-fired power
plants over the next 10 years yes that's
what I said coal be that as it may it
will most likely take decades for India
to catch up with China as the world's
leading manufacturer producer if it ever
does of course this does mean that India
will not become as crucial an economic
player as China is today there is even
one industry that if developed in India
could disrupt many of beijing's
geopolitical plans check it out
[Music]
foreign
the geopolitics of the semiconductor
[Music]
hackers what ronic component does a cell
phone a car or even a guided missile
need in order to work I'm sure some of
you won't know but it's something we
have already talked about on our sister
Channel visual economic if you still
haven't checked it out I'll leave you
the link in the description we are of
course talking about semiconductors and
do you know which country has all the
potential to become a semiconductor
production hotspot you guessed it India
you see Modi does not intend to create
and boost companies from scratch in
India but rather to attract large firms
to the country and that's not crazy
either think about it they have four
advantages a domestic Market extensive
English proficiency a relatively cheap
labor force and one of the largest pools
of science technology engineering and
Mathematics graduates for all these
reasons it is not surprising that we are
already encountering new stories like
these
ismc digital to invest three billion
dollars in chip making unit in Karnataka
Fox Khan and vedanta to build 19 billion
India chip factory and it is precisely
this that is one of China's greatest
fears but the question is why well as
you know India and China are not exactly
the world's best friends they have
conflicting territorial claims and both
countries aspire to become the leading
Regional power in Asia
for example China has been expanding its
power in the South China Sea and even
more worrying for India in other Asian
countries such as Pakistan and Sri Lanka
but for its part India has also been
doing something similar playing on its
geostrategic position in the Andaman
Islands and strengthening ties with
countries such as Oman the Seychelles
and Indonesia crucial locations that
could eventually be used to cut off the
supply of crude oil coming to China by
sea from the Persian Gulf we're talking
about a budding struggle that has
inevitably brought India ever closer to
the United States Biden makes trade-offs
and Modi steps out of his comfort zone
during elaborate State visit at White
House but take note this approach is not
only in modi's own interest but also in
the interest of the Biden Administration
the United States needs India as a
strategic partner to balance against
China in both South Asia and the
indo-pacific and India needs the United
States as it develops a more prosperous
Greener future Caroline gray analyst
Eurasia group 2 2023 we're talking about
an alliance that Washington considers
absolutely key for containing China not
only because of the enormous economic
and political influence that India will
acquire in the coming years and decades
or because this country could be a
natural alternative to the dependence
that the Western world has developed
towards Chinese factories but also for
another very simple reason taiwan's
geopolitical vulnerability and you may
be wondering what does Taiwan have to do
with this well a lot remember that
Taiwan is the world's largest
semiconductor producer
if Taiwanese production were to come to
a sudden halt due to a possible Chinese
Invasion the world would panic and
perhaps a major part of the economy
would also come to a halt semiconductors
are crucial to Industry around the world
precisely for this reason the United
States is investing heavily in this
industry for example in August last year
it passed legislation that included an
investment of more than 50 billion
dollars to strengthen its own
semiconductor production they're also
pushing for Taiwanese companies such as
tsmc to move part of their operations
there tsmc to up Arizona Investment to
40 billion dollars with second
semiconductor chip plant today the
United States produces about 12 of all
semiconductors in the world far behind
Taiwan an island that also produces the
vast majority of the world's most
advanced semiconductors
well if as intended ship production in
countries such as the United States
Japan and India as well as South Korea
were to increase China would lose an
important strategic asset its potential
ability to threaten Western economies
with the invasion of Taiwan would be
greatly reduced
and not only that if India manages to
position itself in this field that would
probably also encourage many technology
companies to relocate their current
production from China to India and as
you can see in this whole story
infrastructure is absolutely crucial
India needs to connect to the world and
make its economy agile and affordable it
needs professionals and goods to be able
to move quickly and cheaply and it also
needs to ensure an abundant and
competitive power supply and now having
come this far the questions are over to
you do you think that India will also
manage to overtake China economically
become a major semiconductor producer
and reduce the risk posed by China you
can leave us your answers in the
comments as promised we now recommend to
you a nature protection channel that we
fully embrace Planet wild is unique
because it shows you how we can protect
nature in simply spectacular and
educational videos Planet wild is a
global community of people that want to
give Back To Nature by funding Frontline
nature Protection work where it has a
huge impact you can also join their fast
growing Community if you feel that we
should do something to protect our
planet we are already part of this
community because we support this
revolutionary way to generate a truly
positive impact on our environment in
their videos you will learn a lot about
nature while seeing what planet wild
does every month to protect it I
recommend watching one of these videos
in which they're restoring a river
ecosystem after millions of fish died
there in an ecological disaster or
saving one of the cutest birds from the
brink of Extinction now go and check
them out and see for yourself take care
see you next time
foreign